i i gotta ask because i've been curious
maybe you can explain it right right
what is up with those pesky black lines
everywhere i look everywhere oh i see
all i see is the pesky black it's just
like a white splat or like the white
splotch or sometimes if there's
keep changing
um
i think it's
well i know it's you know
some
a very uh
complicated dance with the powers that
be okay okay okay because um they'll
come in to a publisher especially and
say
too much
right right right
so yeah so you guys put as little as
possible to not
like anger the people who make up the
rules right the uh well you know people
the publishers keep trying to push the
limits but then there's always push back
yeah
and like when um
tokyo olympics were happening like the
build up to that was just more and more
censorship right really yeah right i
mean they got rid of porn magazines from
combines right because of that they did
yeah that was one of the things that the
tokyo government decided to they were
like we're gonna have a lot of people
coming into japan and we don't want
people coming here for the first time to
walk into a [ __ ] family mud and be
like there's a lot of porn mags here
next to like all the manga that's uh i
never looked at them but i thought they
were still there but i think it must be
like lewd stuff then yeah there's a lot
of like review stuff right but yeah but
like the actual like porn magazines like
there was like you know usually there's
like a curtain you know separating you
know those kinds of like stuff right
like in anywhere but in combinies it was
just there
in the open usually right usually right
next to the toilet yeah you know
it's like it's it's one of those things
where like you go to the toilet and you
take a quick little peek before you go
to the toilet they were like sellotaped
shop
yeah yeah
they're like roped up right yeah yeah no
you all buy it
yeah so they're like that was one of the
things where they were just like we're
just going to eradicate porn max i
didn't realize
you hear from different industries how
kind of like they were on like a blitz
before the olympics and just trying to
clean things up yeah sanitize everything
yeah
i mean they like killed airbnb they uh
yeah
and i think they did a few other things
as well i can't remember they did quite
a lot of things they did so many things
they put a lot of things like
to like science
know just like clean up
like desanitized
like the whole entire industry mm-hmm
really didn't really end up happening
yeah yeah yeah but it has happened in
like because everything is more online
now everything has to sort of conform
to uh western
so you can't have like there used to be
a lot more bestiary but we can't have
that anymore
it needs to be a lot more lonely you
can't have that anymore it's be sure
that i can't have that anymore yeah so
like is there any like is it's so
with regards to the censorship is there
any like rules that have been like put
down on paper like let let's say you
know you you have like a penis or a
vagina is there like a rule to like what
part
like like
of what needs to be blocked out like 10
20 or whatever i think like
it depends on like what you're talking
about because like
usually like if someone's putting a book
out in comiket yeah
the people who run comiket will come by
in the morning check your book out make
sure everything's censored to the
standards of whatever the hentai
industry is doing it at the moment right
so now
things have to be pretty like blacked
out right well like you know 10 years
ago it used to be
you have to have a boy like over the tip
you have to have a bar over like the
little flange
[Laughter]
that's the scientific term
and you have to have a ball like
somewhere on the shaft right right like
anywhere on the shelf like somewhere
anywhere on this side i've seen it just
like in the most random places yeah like
that is doing nice it's like the middle
of the shot and it's like i know what's
behind that
yeah i've always noticed it's always
like the tip and the flange yeah but
then there are some instances where it's
just like
[ __ ] like like just seven lines over
the entire show
it's like a zebra [ __ ] and it's like
so now it's more like minecraft looking
yeah completely blocked out yeah it's
like it's it's like mosaic but it's not
like fully mosaiced if it makes sense
you'll still make it out like i've seen
like a trend recently which is like the
glowy dick
it's like you can make like a faint
outline of the car somewhere around here
it's it's so weird whenever you get that
scene whenever like yeah whenever the
girl takes off the trousers and it's
just like a glowing dick
and it's just the most surreal thing i
don't know who started this trend or how
this trend started
um
like make a scene where like the light
source is coming from that dick
so it works with the censorship
[Laughter]
there's no censorship here yeah my dick
just claws have you ever had to come up
with any creative ways to come around to
get past the censorship well
the easiest way is like you know just
work the angles so you don't have to
show as much right
i feel i feel like also like depending
on like what angles you choose it like
some are even better if you don't like
just completely oh yes absolutely
sometimes it's just like better if you
don't see anything yeah yeah it's it's
paradoxical but like sometimes like you
know
yeah
not seeing the faces sometimes it's like
students seeing the face yeah
yeah actually that's that's that's
interesting like how did you how did you
i guess how do you direct your own sex
scenes you know like how do you know
what looks hot or was it just
kind of like you look at other
references and you're like that looks
kind of good or that there's a tempo to
it like you know you can't have like
money shot money shot money shot because
like you know it just blends all
together yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
need like you know like downtime
downtime money shot you know right right
right although i've read a lot of dozens
where it's just like seven page motor of
money shots
it's like bro like how is this man's
balls not exploded at this point it's
like that's a lot
so
you mentioned obviously uh centering
from the government but is it ever hard
when you're trying to you know dealing
with almost
self-censorship like you're like ah is
this too much i don't know [ __ ]
well you know personally i try to like
push boundaries right right like
whatever makes me feel uncomfortable
like sometimes i try to delve into that
just like you know get a feeling for it
right yeah yeah myself basically
yeah do you feel like that uncomfortable
feeling enhances your story is is that
what you would say it makes it more
interesting
but you're not doing it like purely for
like shock factor it's not shock factor
it's just like
to catch my own interest and like right
it's not for any like deeper meaning
really but like
i mean
i think it makes the work more like
unique unique and spicy it's a little
spicy yeah i'm surprised that you said
that the
white i guess overseas norms affects
the
japanese senses because normally
people are under the impression that
japan doesn't give a [ __ ] what the
outside world thinks i mean the standard
anime industry definitely is the case
right yeah it's strange if the anime
industry doesn't care but then i guess
if to hear the arrow stuff kind of maybe
is more affected by what other countries
think and what i think maybe it's
because like the dojin industry actually
cares for the like international
community even like the normal anime
stuff like um they're remaking they're
remaking
right yeah yeah yeah yeah and like the
foot one of the first scenes is like a
booby shot yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
what's going to happen
you don't know are we going to conform
to like you know global standards or
you're just going to go with the 80s you
know right yeah like complete remake
yeah yeah i guess like
when you
make your work do you have to keep this
keep this into account or was it trying
not to yeah like
i don't know it's it's fantasy right so
like yeah
like
oh
it's gonna be annoying
yeah yeah i mean
oh this conversation i've had this one
like before more than once right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
like um
how do you go about like making
something and like
make it like
because you know it's not socially
acceptable yeah yeah i think
when it's art right it has to be done
tastefully or appropriately right yeah
to be like okay you know you need to
have stories about stuff like this
because it happens you know like i don't
necessarily personally agree with it but
yeah i am okay with this is obviously
honestly an author you don't your
characters aren't you right yeah they're
there to represent something and to push
a a storyline and it's because you write
about a story i think anyone i i i don't
really agree with people like you can't
write about x topics it's like no i mean
if this stuff happens in real life it it
happens in real life yeah yeah why shy
away from it horrible stuff happens all
the time you should be able to write a
story about it
obviously there are some people who do
it not tastefully at all yeah the
argument i hear a lot is that it
normalizes the uh the act right yeah i i
disagree with that no i disagree i
disagree too but like you know i hear it
a lot yeah yeah